[Music]
[Applause]
yay
yo it's october boom
so therefore we're gonna play carry on
this game looks super exciting let's go
yeah it's been a while
okay i'm afraid
now this is not your typical horror game
i don't know anything about it i just
know that it's
not what you expect i go here
[Music]
oh wait am i the monster oh yeah
that's so cool
you scared oh you scared
where am i oh i vented hello
yes i want to kill so bad
this is so cool where do i go through
the pipes
so i can grab objects now all right
should i grab this perhaps yes
yes yes can i go up here
no all right
[Music]
grab humans okay let's go this is dope
i love the pixel style too very nice
oh oh it oh you're taking a little
pooper there
you're having a bad day he's having a
bad day let's leave him
it's all right let's leave him we're not
he can live uh do i have to kill him
man i'm so sorry about this bro so sorry
about this
oh jesus christ
i'm stronger now yes
yes yes yes
20 muscle increase oh
hell yeah
okay all right we out here oh dude i
gotta eat a banana right now
wait a minute is that me playing this
game
what the hell is that
don't be scared don't be scared don't be
scared
where am i you don't know you can't hide
but you can run i mean you
you're dead you're dead basically don't
go don't go i love you
squeezing oh wait there was more people
to kill
i should have eaten before sorry
any last words any
oh jesus christ
tastes good man i wonder if humorous
tastes like bananas i was thinking about
this the other day
i was thinking about poop and how it
smells bad
but surely that's just something we
evolved out of survival purposes to
smell certain things badly
so maybe poop doesn't actually smell bad
you know what i mean
yeah i think you got my point i'm glad i
brought that up in a video
let's go
okay good we have no weaknesses i
thought it was going to be something
lame where we can't touch the sun or
something
what dude it's me charlie let me in
please
i swear i sway
oh god spread biomass
oh i'm spreading whoa okay
okay oh oh
we open we're opening portals to hell
and [ __ ]
oh hell yeah oh mama mia
all right now we can go right come on
it's me
it's charlie let me in i say man
all right it's a puzzle it's a puzzle
sorry i got this
i'm smart i'm really smart trust me
maybe we need to grab a human and put
them there right
yeah let's grab you
[Laughter]
legs at last no i ate them
[ __ ] squeezing oh
i wasn't i was too smart for the game
let's get real here
frontier wastelands
hey hey hey hey how's everyone doing
maybe monsters aren't so bad after all
you know oh
he doesn't suspect the thing yes
hmm he's so pure
so innocence hmm try going this way
whoa look at the tentacles japanese
people be like
bruh nice
oh we're in water can we breathing water
no weaknesses
come on i need that 20 gains bruh okay
all right we keep going there's the
lever what does that do
maybe there's some backtracking
happening later i'm very smart
basically thank you in case you're new
and haven't figured out anything about
me very smart thank you
now we can grab this for some reason oh
my god the music's so dramatic i love it
i'll bring you with me for good luck
you're my favorite barrel
and he died this is so sad f in the chat
warning oh no biological threat
i wonder what they're talking about
surely can't be me
yeah i'm so nasty dude i kind of like it
though
it's kind of hot not sure what category
this game will be
horror hentai don't shoot don't shoot
jerry put down gun i'm innocence
hello oh oh leg all right let the legs
live
jerry's leg gets to live you're welcome
jerry
now let's see here yes actually i bring
jared's leg with me
don't oh my god why god damn it i know
where should i happen
spread the biomass yo
all right we spreading thick boys hell
yeah
spread those sheets
oh no oh
getting bigger yeah
yeah all right don't shoot please it's
me
he thinks it's us someone vented it's me
ah [ __ ] shot me dude
okay i feel better so i can die i guess
i've had that health bar there and see
it until then
[Applause]
oh god yes it's
yes
never forget like and like that thank
you
[Applause]
this is so dope i love this
i want to become really vague i want to
see how big you can become
wait retrieve biomass yeah i'll get some
biomass
give me that biomass bro yeah
we're growing a little slower i need to
figure out how to eat more humans
is that more of me oh
mini me there we go there we go
yes squeeze
new dna absorbed arachnoph yes
shoot a cobweb oh
i can shoot the cobble and hit the lever
nice
yes yes yes yes yes
yes you will all pay
for keeping me caged this is corpse here
guys
hello this is how i talk such a strange
game
makes you think why no one's done this
before don't shoot don't shoot
don't shoot can i hit him with a cobweb
from here
man's be like what she's fine she's fine
she's fine trust me
tastes very
all good all right stop screaming you're
going to alert the guards
cringe bro
[Music]
and up we go ah frick
backtracking we do all right nice shirt
bro you suit pink
i won't shoot you i won't shoot you i
won't shoot him he gets to live
i like him
of course why someone squealing over
here
[Applause]
stop crying stop crying please cringe
die with honor please
you want to squeeze in bruh this game
makes me hungry is that weird
i feel like yeah that's weird
hey hey biomass sample loss 100
50 breach containment unit locked
okay oh oh
what a what
am i controlling the people i am hey
guys
don't let it say follow me i control the
mind of the innocents
where do you think i am america after
election no problem
let's go here guys trust me
yeah this is good
yes ladder you like ladders uh don't
worry we're special teams unit here
let's examine that yep that is an
anti-deviluvian match yes i know my job
and this is a great how are you two
for you do nothing can i run i can't run
okay i should have asked myself that
sooner
do i have to survive it's his character
i kind of i want him to die right
uh yes philosophical game
makes you question which side you're on
planet c4 excuse me
oh run run run
uh guys guys come here come here
guys trust me trust trust oh oh
she's connect oh girl all right how far
is this okay all right let me hit it for
you girl
yeah i love this you never know what's
gonna happen next
very spoopy yes
okay okay not sure what the point of
save is
we've been never near dying which will
never happen
we're going back to the humans no
you're alien okay
hello
[Music]
[Laughter]
i threw up a little bit hello
you like these legs you like the legs
boy come on
it's me hey look it's your buddy
look it's me i'm just like you i swear
ah oh you'll pay for it
you'll pay for all how could you
i'm just trying to be like one of you
guys
[ __ ] legs dude just because i don't
have one
i get the message of the game now
anti-leg rhetoric
right yeah oh
oh wow rxd
rxd come on
come
took a while to eat that snack
tastes good yeah
oh we have four marble
hey don't you come on man legs are
actually
a delicacy of humans don't ask me how i
know
just ask me why you haven't tried oh we
came from here sorry
jesus christ almost felt bad for that
one all right upper left all right
uh oh these guys will do a lot of damage
don't they
oh what is that he's alive trust me look
look he's alive he's fine
hey holmes hey alms he's fine
he keeps throwing him around oh it's a
suit
it's a suit that's so cute he's adorable
all right shaky shaky
squeezing sarofia that sounds like a
type of poop damage vent covers and
wooden walls
oh cool we couldn't do that before let's
wait
oh we're getting strong now yes
this feels like old school how's it
going bro so my name is peter pan
this game is so cool wow
but it actually is how about that wow oh
we're big
oh we're very big look how big
so large now we can go here sweet
we can't go there though i want to eat
everyone and everything
uranium mines okay
hey hey
[Music]
he's fine he's fine he's fine oh god i'm
bigger now
it comes with a prize to get bigger
never thought of that
aloha politely open doors still nom nom
nom
nom nom no no no this is ridiculous i'm
just eating everyone
hello hello sorry
sorry sorry i'm on it honestly i didn't
want to do it honestly i did not want to
do it
okay maybe a little bit
i like the batman like soundtrack
because i'm mine all day it's got that
terraria graphics i like it
a mine all night on my non-stop
if those diamonds are inside and
mine yours yes
she's fine trust me deposit biomass
i made a baby that's adorable
hello make a baby
hey guys no no no no no
they didn't hear ah come on they heard
me
sorry i'll make it quick i'll make it
quick i'm really sorry about this
i'm really i feel bad i made it quick
at least i'm a good monster you know how
to make them suffer
i became a biomass guys see if i'm too
big i get different abilities so now
that i'm smaller i can shoot the cobweb
but i can't use the
things i have to go back and get my
beefy back
yes there it is no
not deposit eat it eat it eat it eat it
now we can do
this sweet yeah
we're getting big one it's so weird i
can't stop playing
i want to just go big man we're homies
we homies trust me
oh they got the electrical thing
they're shooting me and i'm innocent
ah [ __ ] this
oh god i'm almost dead i'm so tiny and
pathetic
come come come
[Music]
yes i got him eat
stronger yes
stronger oh
oh they taste like [ __ ] though
damn did i [ __ ] that up i'm so weak now
let me let me just eat you guys please
i'm i'm starving dude
thank you i'm seriously so hungry
i feel much better now warning this
facility is protected by
the automated drone oh oh no
kill the drone
drone be gone yes thank you
it's me a real human trust me you can
trust me
i'm not an alien but i'm not there's
nothing weird about me right you
understand me
you understand do you understand me
there's nothing
you want one too all right let's keep
going boys
you can't jump with this character it's
a bit awkward but i can't climb ladders
like a boss
did i just run away from my teammates oh
all right maybe we should go back damn
all right i'm strong too huh god damn
all right left or right it feels like a
right one doesn't it
why am i oh there's a dead body here
this is so sad massive head trauma
hey guys what's up we did it
good job nice job team that's like a bad
idea it feels like we're just gonna let
it out but hey
sometimes you just gotta let it out oh
yeah yucky blocky
don't touch my baby keep calm and carry
on all right
oh okay we in the jungle boys
what are you doing in the jungle boy
yuck oh i'm actually grossed out i look
so ugly maybe the right instagram filter
i'll look better
that's fine it's cozy i liked it
the hell is your problem yeah ah
at the burn we have to trick him oh my
god ah
stop he he doesn't see me he doesn't see
that
just eat him just eat him [ __ ] i'm
innocence
all right we got you going in the water
with me god damn
oh no i gotta eat you bro i'm sorry
i gotta heal all of you because i gotta
go don't run don't run i'll make it
painless
i make it painless crunch crunch crunch
crunch crunch crunch
i need more i need more i need more
i need more i'm hungry still
sorry i closed the door
i gotta go up i gotta go all the way and
i gotta say hello to you
you make me stronger right yeah and then
we go back
and yeah no yeah yeah
no boop boop
okay here i am don't flamethrower me i
don't like they
oh dude they're camping
i got it i got it i got it
stupid stupid
yeah no problem i like that security
measure where
if you destroy all the security then the
doors open
whoever designed that
i didn't do nothing
okay i feel better oh no i gotta eat
homes so unfair i wish i had a
flamethrower
boom hey it's me don't shoot it's your
mom
knock knock ah
you can sat me peekaboo
no i'm so small and pathetic
oh my god actually died are you serious
don't look good don't look don't look
away that is not that's not can we all
know that doesn't count
come on hey how you doing girl
yes photo candice's ben light to create
an invisibility cloak
requires energy cloak master 64 oh
yes
[Laughter]
yes we cloak
oh god it won't last long you won't let
oh
oh that was the miller second all right
hug me
i don't have the cloak anymore i'm too
large hello
don't hurt me
he's fine
ah he's got the [ __ ] flamethrower
that's cheat he's cheating
oh yeah i'm invisible i can do the
invisible meme
yeah let's do that
but i'm invisible yeah yeah get me make
me invisible
i'm invisible stop stop it stop it
all right he doesn't see me he doesn't
see me all right so i go invisible
yeah eat him
eat him eat him oh he's not dead
oh my god oh my god clutch clutch clutch
all right here comes here comes
you'll never know what happened
yes yes taste the good
i eat we're large we're an extra large
big mac right now baby
yes yes yes oh we need to be invisible
though i got to make a baby here
all right i got an idea i got an idea if
she just
shoots me then i'll lose health and then
i need you to have courage girl
all right all right fine fine i make
baby i make the baby i made the baby
you understand what i do for you girl i
make baby for you girl
you understand all right now i'm
invisible
it's me
i did it i did it i beat the game
i beat it not really
but i think that's a good time to end it
cool game
i think i might play more of this on the
stream if you guys are interested but
definitely had a lot of fun cool game
very nice if you enjoyed a lot more live
like smash subscribe
and all that good stuff thanks for
watching i appreciate you being here
uh i hope that was fun because i had fun
rufus
[Music]